birthdays were invented by Hallmark to
sell cards
yes this is your original intern
application your original parking pass
this is your original photo ID did you
get that out of my purse it doesn't
matter and this is a copy of your very
first paycheck who's that from me it's
from me happy birthday thank you Leslie
open mine it is it's nice I mean it can
be a little sappy and sentimental to
kind of frame things but it's always
nice to remember the beginning of
something you know the start and when
you have that oh geez run for God's sake
she's an adult now she should know how
to responsibly handle and discharge a
weapon that there's a Sig Sauer 22
caliber mosquito manufactured in
Switzerland for their [__] police force
this two-tone lightweight model is
perfect for a skinny little thing like
you
gee thanks prom
I will hold on to this for you until we
get you licensed up
and that'll take you for some target
practice
goody yeah I do feel a little guilty
I'm re-gifting
bye good morning
I know how much you enjoy paperwork but
don't hover nice bench is that new
no that's been there since the 90s what
are you doing for your birthday on
Friday nothing I never
oh God birthday birthday it's your
birthday it's your birthday and I know
when it is Ron refuses to tell anyone
when his birthday is he's even had it
redacted on all government documents
three years of Investigations phone
calls Freedom of Information Act
requests and still I had nothing until a
well-placed bribe to a gentleman at
Baskin Robbins revealed
Ron's birthday is on Friday damn it I
was so careful
I blew it all for a free scoop of rum
raisin was it worth it Ron was it I
command you to do nothing I'm not gonna
do nothing do something and it's
up for
I don't like loud noises and people
making a fuss and I especially don't
like people celebrating because they
know a piece of private information
about me
plus the whole thing is a scam birthdays
were invented by Hallmark to sell cards
okay well I am on operation no more
fence so I'm putting you in charge of
operation Ron's party colon shock and
awe I'm all over it I just need you to
do what's on that list Leslie has a lot
of qualities I find horrifying but the
worst one by far is how thoughtful she
can be
yes hi I have a question about your
inflatable saxophones
do those come in different sizes I'm
going to need about 40 dozen of those
also what about your neon gangster
fedora hats um
that was rude whatever's going on here
stop it immediately I was just talking
on the phone to whom it was personal I
would never make a work related call you
know that
Hey Ron how's the street parking at your
house what can you handle like 20 cars
or a double decker party bus
there is no street parking at my house
my house is not even on a street do you
have space for like a huge circus tent
Hey Ron have you seen what the hell no
oh well looks like there won't be any
balloons for the birthday boy these were
for a sick child at the hospital
my office now
how are you don't care I'm only going to
ask you this once what is going on with
my birthday oh my God Ron it's your
birthday happy
birthday shut your damn mouth it's a fun
conversation just tell me what Leslie is
planning honestly I I don't know I
haven't heard anything why don't you
tell me what she did for your last
birthday oh well that was intense she
totally surprised me she kidnapped me
from work and then she took me to that
place in your Vegas you know where the
mariachi band comes out they put a big
Sombrero on you and everybody sings
Happy Birthday and then we went back to
my house and she invited basically
everyone I knew and she had this great
guy doing face painting and I had my
face painted like a fairy tiger
also she did it like a week before my
birthday which is genius because I had
no idea it was coming and then there was
a bouncy castle did you know they made
those for adults
um
you want me to do what now send Leslie
somewhere on an assignment a conference
or something and make her take April and
freeze their bank accounts I don't
understand is Leslie's work
unsatisfactory no it has nothing to do
with her work
I don't want to get into it
fine this is me okay
you know you can talk to me about
anything
well
it's it's my birthday on Friday hey
happy birthday
I'm ending this right now I'm just gonna
leave early and go home
unless
that's exactly what she wants me to do
morning Ron
ooh dude you forgot to put a shirt on I
do it all the time it's fine I slept
here sweet so a little birdie told me
it's your birthday coming up how about a
free birthdays you shine what did this
little birdie tell you is going to
happen for my birthday nice try Ron
you're not getting anything out of me
Andrew please run
look I love you like a father who's not
that much older than me like a young
uncle or like uh you're my camp
counselor but we're adults so we hang
out and it's not weird you know or
actually here's what it is you're my
lacrosse coach I get it I get it what's
the point well coach Leslie swore me to
secrecy so I can't say anything I over
so much I can't ruin it for her well I
respect that
see you later okay not if I see you
first uncle Ron
and I probably will because Leslie
assigned me to the kidnap Squad
hey did you hear the news Ben and Chris
want us to go in a conference room seat
for a meeting
let's get this over with
happy birthday Ron
and said you had a big party sombreros
karaoke I did that for Anne why would I
throw Ron Swanson and Ann Perkins party
what about the giant list of things
April was doing that was just a list of
ways to ways to mess with you
she do them all she did indeed
so I have rented Bridge on the River
Kwai and The Dirty Dozen
Artie from security is outside the door
so no one will bother you and a cab will
be here whenever you're ready to take
you home
thank you do you remember what you said
to me five years ago when Eagleton
offered me that job and I asked you for
your advice
uh do whatever the hell you want what do
I care right but then
after when I pressed you
what did you say
I believe I said that I thought we
worked well together and that I might
disagree with your philosophy but I
respected you
and I said that you'll get a lot of job
offers in your life
but you only have one hometown
that's how I remember it
this by the way is a one-time only
situation next year your birthday party
is going to be a rager
[Music]
Leslie thanks to your annoying prying
last year I'm sure you remember my
birthday is coming up I know I know no
parties you hate parties correct
oh you know that wild goose chase you
sent Ben on for Valentine's Day the
scavenger hunt I also do not want that
yep I understand I absolutely do not
want to solve a series of riddles and
clues each more intricate than the last
you understand what I'm saying yeah I
got it Ron good
I do want that please do that for me